there are several ways to search pubmed
by journal you may search by the
complete journal title the international
standard serial number or issn
or by the medline journal title
abbreviation
note that using only a partial journal
title will not retrieve the best results
from pubmed
let's try a search for the journal of
pediatric surgery in pubmed
click search
your results will include all of the
citations in pubmed from this journal
you may wish to sort your results by
most recent for this type of search
click on the most recent sort button
if your journal title is also a subject
term like cell cancer or pediatrics or
if you are unsure of the exact journal
title use the advanced search to avoid
problems searching for your journal
in the search builder section
select journal
enter several characters from the
journal name in the search box
select the journal title from the
autocomplete menu
click add to add the journal to the
query box
click search to find all works in pubmed
from this journal
you